also alle die ich kenne schämen sich
sind auch wütend und und vor allen
dingen haben jetzt auch alle angst dass
da alle auf meiner seite meine freunde
die leute die ich gerne dass da jemand
sitzt er sagt wenn ich jetzt also wenn
der beiden letztlich mit lance sei es
leid wie die habe ich sagen also mit
einem riesen riesen vorsprung gewinnt
dann wird der song ich erkennen die wahl
nicht an oder so also viele fürchten
sich davor also leute bis zu bill maher
der im fernsehen ständig predigt und
sagen was machen wir wenn er die wahl
nicht anerkennt sie sagen gerade alle
ihre freunde an menschen die sie kennen
das zeigt ja dass es doch eine sehr
große spaltung in amerika gibt meistens
in den eigenen freundeskreisen
einkreisen die man sich bewegt ist man
entweder bei demokrat oder republikaner
wie groß haben sie die spaltung
mitbekommt vor allem wie groß ist sie
jetzt in den in diesem jahr geworden die
haben immer wieder ausschreitungen
gesehen wirklich erschreckend waren
na ja ich lebe in kalifornien
kalifornien ist ja demokratisch und alle
mit denen ich zu tun habe
sind demokratisch und und ich kann mir
auch nicht vorstellen wie man trump
anhänger sein kann und jemandem
befreundet sein zu können ich mit meinen
arbeiten zu können wahrscheinlich sogar
weiß ich nicht aber ich möchte mit weiß
ich nicht ich bin doch nicht in die lage
gekommen wie ich kenne keinen der der
großer trump vertreter oder anhänger ist
aber natürlich polarisiert das
unheimlich und und er führt das ja auch
angler und also im ganzen finde ich
jetzt auch nicht als politiker ich rede
einfach als emotionaler normal denkender
mensch und auch mir das aber nie
entdeckt wenn sie sagen dem zwar gesagt
dass aus ihrer sicht donald trump ebenso
viele lügen verbreitet habe dass da so
viel schlimmes passiert ist im letzten
jahr
wie erklären sie sich dass jetzt gerade
in den letzten tagen die umfragen wieder
näher aneinander gekommen sind
warum ist das so dass ich mir nicht
erklären bin kein politiker aber nicht
also wenn er den mund aufmacht schon
wenn er sagt the great time als ich hier
wir hören im fernsehen jeden tag 20 mal
wenn er schon so an höre ich auf zu
zuhören weil ich weiß ich selbst noch
geschützt da wollen wir vielleicht dann
auch einmal noch unsere top 1 zeigen
denn sie haben angefangen mit dem satz
wir haben alle benehmen gelernt und
genau bei diesen szenen haben viel an
den benehmen von donald trump gezeichnet
[Musik]
also dafür dass wir gehört immer wieder
gesagt angela merkel ist mein best
friends meine beste freundin hier will
er noch nicht mal die hand gebe sitzt da
sehr stur
sie lachen wenn sie die bilder sehen war
ich mache also aus verzweiflung das ist
ja wirklich kann man sich ja nicht an
schon das ist also auch ein präsident
steht ja als symbol oder als als als als
beispiel und als vertreter für für ein
land und das ist auch keiner von dem ich
vertreten werden möchte möchte dass da
keiner wo er so sagen die habe ich auch
wieder also als wir was sagen die ihren
kindern sagen wenn so kann man sich ja
das ist meine meinung ich sehe sie sind
da ganz anders unterwegs aber ich habe
eigentlich dann gar keine gar keine
richtige meinung also ich finde es so zu
sagen wenn wir jetzt donald trump
betrachten ich finde es aus
journalistischer perspektive einfach
wahnsinnig spannend warum wenn ist
ebenso viele menschen gibt die sagen er
hat jetzt so viel falsch gemacht der so
viele lügen verbreitet wie es dann
eigentlich sein kann dass so viele leute
noch auf seiner seite stehen und wie er
so erfolgreich sein kann das eigentlich
eher die frage die ich mir stelle jahr
das ist eine frage des
intelligenzquotienten glaube ich mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bate schau dich hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren